In this video, I want to solve some of the issues that contain
On the properties of the foundations
But, before doing so, let's do
A quick review of what the basics are
Suppose I have 2 ^ 3
You might say, is this worth 6?
I will tell you no, not worth 6
But this means that the 2 multiplied by itself three times
Ie Sisawe 2 × 2 × 2, where
2 x 2 = 4
4 × 2 = 8
If you ask, how much output 3 ^ 2?
It means you will hit 3 herself twice
Ie 3 x 3
It is equal to 9
Let's do one more solution
I think you've absorbed the general idea, if you have not
I've seen this before
Suppose I have 5 ^ 7
Which is equal to 5 multiplied by itself seven times
5 × 5 × 5 × 5 × 5 × 5 × 5
These seven times, right?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven
The output will be quite a very large number
I will not calculate it now
If you want to count it yourself, it is up to you
Or use the calculator to do this, but assure you that output
very big
So what you will quickly recognize is
The foundations raise the value of the numbers quickly
The V517 would produce a huge and massive number
But in any case, this was a simple review of the basics
Let us now go deeper into algebra, using the foundations
Let's say 3x output - let me do this in a different color -
How much output is 3x × 3x × 3x?
Well, the thing you should remember about the beating
Is, that ranking does not matter when you do an operation
Multiply
So the issue can be written in the following picture 3 × 3 × 3
X x x x x x
The issue of ranking is due to us, this part
Here, 3 × 3 × 3, equals
3 ^ 3
This part, x multiplied by itself three times
X x 3
The result can be written as follows
3 ^ 3 × x ^ 3
Or if you know the output of 3 ^ 3, which is 9 × 3
It is equal to 27
The final output is 27x ^ 3
Maybe you're saying now, it's not a matter of 3x × 3x × 3x
Ie (3x) ^ 3?
is not it?
I beat 3x herself three times
I will tell you, yes it is
These can be interpreted as
(3x) ^ 3
Thus, we have dealt with one
Of the characteristics of the foundations
They gave this
When I have a number multiplied by a number, and every amount
Raised to power 3, this equals every value of them
3 These values ​​are multiplied by each other
If (3x) ^ 3 equals 3 ^ 3 ×
x ^ 3, ie 27x ^ 3
Let us solve more examples
What if you asked how much output 6 ^ 3 ×
6 ^ 6?
The output will be quite huge, but I want
Write it in a number that is raised to power 6
Let me write 6 ^ 6 in a different color
6 ^ 3 × 6 ^ 6, km
Result of the matter?
Well, 6 ^ 3, we know it's about 6 multiplied
Herself three times
Ie 6 × 6 × 6
This amount is multiplied by - I will write the multiplication signal
In green
Use orange to write two numbers
This equals 6 × 6
Well, how much output 6 ^ 6?
He's 6 multiplied by herself six times
Ie 6 × 6 × 6 × 6 × 6
× 6 Other
How much would it be?
Well, we'll beat 6 here by herself
How many times?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven
Eight, nine times, right?
Three times here, plus 6 times
If we hit her own nine times
3 + 6
This equals 6 ^ 3 + 6 or
6 ^ 9
And so we have touched on
Another property of the properties of the foundations
In this case, when we dealt with the foundations, 6 ^ 3
The number 6 was the foundation
Ie we took the raised basis of force 3
When we multiply two numbers
They have the same foundation, in which case the foundations are gathered
Let me resolve several issues on this
I will use purple
Suppose I have 2 ^ 2 × 2 ^ 4 ×
2 ^ 6
Well, we have the same foundation for all these values, if
We can gather the foundations
This equals 2 ^ 2 + 4 + 6
It is equal to 2 ^ 12
This is logical, because we have
2 multiplied by herself twice, 2 multiplied by herself four times
And 2 multiplied by itself six times
When we multiply all these values, output 2 will be multiplied by itself
12 times, or 2 ^ 12
Let me do it briefly, using some
Variables, but the idea remains the same
How much is x ^ 2 or x ^ 2 × x ^ 4
Well, we can use the property we learned
We have the same foundation, ie x
Thus the output will be x ^ 2 + 4
Ie x ^ 6
If you do not believe me, how much is x ^ 2 output?
x ^ 2 = x x x
If we want to hit this b
x ^ 4, means that we will multiply the amount by x multiplied by itself four times
x x x x x x x
In the end, how many times will we beat X herself?
Well, one, two, three, four, five, six times
x ^ 6
Let's have one more solution
It is better for us to solve more examples
We now move on to the next property, even
We combine it with other properties
Suppose I have (a ^ 3) ^ 4
I will tell you what the property is, and explain why
Are logical
When we raise the number of a particular bass, then raise
The whole amount is for another, so we can strike the foundations
Here the output will be a ^ 3 × 4 ie
a ^ 12
What is considered logical?
Well, because we have a ^ 3 here
Multiplied by itself four times
Which equals a ^ 3 × a ^ 3
× a ^ 3 × a ^ 3
Well, we have the same foundation, so we can gather the foundations
Ie the output will be ^ 3 × 4
This equals a ^ 3 + 3 + 3 + 3
It is the same as 3 x 4
Which equals a ^ 12
Let's review the characteristics we learned
In this lesson, along with a review
The basics, if we had x ^ a × b
This will equal
x ^ a + b
We have seen this here
x ^ 2 × x ^ 4 =
x ^ 6, ie the output of 2 + 4
We also saw that if we had (x x y) ^ a
This is equivalent to x ^ a
× y ^ a
We've seen it in this video
Here at the top
3x ^ 3 is equivalent to 3 ^ 3 ×
x ^ 3
That's all I said before
3x ^ 3 is equivalent to 3 ^ 3 ×
x ^ 3
And the last property
If we have x ^ a and then raise all the amount of force b
Equals x ^ a × b
We also saw this, where if we had a ^ 3 and raised it
For force 4, this is equal to a ^ 3 × 4
Ie a ^ 12
So let's apply these properties to a set of
More complex issues. For example, say (2xy) ^ 2 ×
(-x ^ 2 y) ^ 2 ×
(3x ^ 2 y ^ 2)
We want to simplify them
And the best value to start with is to simplify
This phrase is to make it look
-1 × x ^ 2 × y ^ 2
If we took this part and we squared it, that would be
As each statement of power is raised separately 2
If this part can be simplified to -1 ^ 2
X x ^ 2 × y ^ 2
Hence if we simplify it, -1 ^ 2
= 1, x ^ 2-- Remember that you can
To hit the foundations - equals
x ^ 4 y ^ 2
This is simplifying the middle part
Let us now see if it can be combined with other parts
The other parts are, 2xy ^ 2
And 3x ^ 2 y ^ 2
Well, now we can continue
Multiply the values ​​together
We have learned that it is in the multiplication process
The order of values ​​does not matter
So I can change the order
We will hit 2 × x × y ^ 2
X x ^ 4 × y ^ 2 × 3 ×
x ^ 2 × y ^ 2
I can rearrange this arrangement
In a way that makes simplification easier
I can hit 2 × 3, and then go to
Phrases x
Let me use this color
I have x x x x ^ 4 x x ^ 2
Now y, y × 2
× y ^ 2 × y ^ 2
× y ^ 2 again
Now what is the outcome of this?
Well, 2 x 3
Of course we know how much they produce
Equals 6
The output of x × x ^ 4 × x ^ 2
Well, the thing to remember here is that x is about
x ^ 1
For any number raised to Force 1, the output is the same number
As you know, 2 ^ 1 = 2
And 3 ^ 1 = 3
How much is this?
Equally - we have the same foundation as x
So we can combine the bases, x ^ 1 + 4 + 2
I will combine in the next step
Then the y statements,
× y ^ 2 + 2 + 2
How much will the product?
It will be 6x ^ 7
y ^ 6
I will leave you with a question and I think you
You know his answer, which is interesting
What happens when we raise
Number of strength 0?
If I assume I have 7 ^ 0, how much is equal?
I will tell you - this shows that
Obviously - equal to 1, and 1 ^ 0
Equals 1 too
Any number is raised to 0, I mean any number other than zero
When lifting the force 0 will be produced 1
This will give you some
Intuition for Reason
Think of it this way
3 Let me write the powers
Or 2 or 3
We will use base 3
If 3 ^ 1 = 3
I think this is logical
3 ^ 2 = 9
3 ^ 3 = 27
Of course, we try to find an output
3 ^ 0
Think about it
Each time we subtract the value of the exponent
Each time we subtract the value of the exponent by 1, therefore
We divide by 3
Let's move from 27 to 9, divide by 3
Let's move from 9 to 3, also divide by 3
So if we move from this expanse to that, we may have to
Divide on 3 again
Therefore, any number we raise to force 0, and in these
Our case, 3 ^ 0 = 1
See you in the next view